[Musique]
mes chers amis je m'attendais à ce que
la salle soit pleine
mais je ne m'attendais pas à ce qu'elle
soit si pleines et donc je vous félicite
de cette mobilisation dans un territoire
qui bien sûr est coeur au coeur de
l'attention de laurent wauquiez mais qui
le lui rend bien et je vais faire une
petite annonce que je devrais pas faire
mais dans un pays de culture et de
civilisation cher françois xavier
les plus jeunes laissent les chaises aux
dames
je voudrais saluer joseph qui solide
reste à la tête du bpe avec lequel nous
avons une filiation mais permettez moi
sans citer d'autres personnes de saluer
michèle alliot-marie et lui dire combien
on lui reconnaissant d'avoir toujours
porter les valeurs qui sont les nôtres
dans des missions exceptionnelles
elle est là vous la police est très très
fort
j'ai un peu chauvin aussi parce que pour
tout dire michel day est aussi fidèle à
ma ville et donc je la vois souvent
antibes vous le savez
[Applaudissements]
mon cher l'oromia menu est bienvenu
hervé hatt à droite peut pas se mettre
au centre l'ail et d'obliger détour d'un
côté ou de l'autre il a choisi d'être
apte à droite merci d'être là hervé et
des interruptions de discours qui dans
le passé m'avait paru moins agréable
alors vous le savez vous êtes le
parlement vous êtes parlement de notre
parti le parlement de notre parti
laurent wauquiez veut que vous soyez
beaucoup plus associé à l'avenir à aux
décisions que nous prenons
vous avez beaucoup travaillé sur les
aides piliers et aujourd'hui on a un
projet que vous allez voter mais dans
l'avenir on va retravailler sur les
valeurs parce que les valeurs c'est le
socle sur lequel on porte un projet et
ses valeurs il faut qu'elle soit re
immuable parce que les valeurs ne change
pas au gré du vent
mais il faut qu'elles soient aussi
réaffirmé au moment où les uns ou les
autres nous considèrent quelquefois trop
à gauche droite
quelquefois trop à gauche nous sommes
directement et au peuple
c'est ça le plus important pour notre
formation politique
je voudrais vous dire aussi que dans ces
élections qui arrivent
certains ont peu tendance à les
minimiser après tout c'est que des
européennes faut savoir quand même que
c'est la première échéance électorale
après l'élection d' emmanuel macron et
donc c'est le premier test les sondages
vous savez ce que j'en pense les
sondages s'il était vrai je pense que
strauss kahn aurait succédé à edouard
balladur et alain juppé serait président
de la république et qu'on le déplore ou
qu'on ne déplore pas en tout cas
aujourd'hui
les sondages c'est un indicateur de
l'instant et donc on va bousculer les
sondages
et une fois de plus les français et vous
vous allez donner tort à ceux qui nous
placent en queue de peloton et faire en
sorte que ce test soit un test à la fois
pour dire au président de la république
notre mécontentement mais aussi un
engagement européen et cet engagement
européen je pense qu'il faut le faire
dans dans deux contextes majeur la
lucidité et la clarté
la lucidité franchement ça nous amène
pas à un optimisme béat
l'europe est de plus en plus isolé dans
le monde et la france est de plus en
plus isolé en europe
l'europe c'est l'endroit dans lequel est
née une culture une civilisation elle a
été capable de conquérir le monde par sa
technique et elle l'a dominée elle n'a
pas un excusé et aujourd'hui vous le
voyez bien nous sommes effacé européens
au sein du monde les usa par la chine au
dessus de notre dos et nous ne sommes
plus capables d'émettre une puissance
suffisante sur le plan diplomatique et
même sur le plan militaire la france
elle est isolée en europe
je parle pas sur la période qui s'est
passée la période qui s'est passé avec
françois hollande ont été absents
maintenant on est méprisé faut dire
qu'on a donné des leçons à tout le monde
et l'amateurisme associé à l'arrogance
du président de la république a fait en
sorte qu'on ne parle plus à personne
peut-être encore aux grecs qui veulent
bien nous entendre
la main tendue aux espagnols qui ont une
parenthèse socialiste mais dans ce
contexte là moi j'ai envie de retrouver
l'europe et j'ai envie de retrouver la
france et donneurs de leçons ne sont pas
ceux qui agissent et comment voulez vous
qu'on croit un président de la
république qui explique à l'europe
comment va gérer l'immigration
comment on va gérer l'économie comme en
avait géré les finances quand il échoue
sur ses plans sur le plan national la
deuxième élément c'est la clarté la
clarté elle est de notre côté
aujourd'hui sur la base des sept piliers
que nous avons définies à menton il ya
un projet vous l'avez en main il est
étudié il est clair il est réaliste
il est conforme chaire joseph à ce qu'on
pense au sein du ppe et lorsque les élus
européens que nous aurons siègeront à
strasbourg je dis bien à strasbourg
à ce moment là ils iront au ppe faudra
qu'on m'explique où vont les autres et
en particulier ceux qui sont en marche
on sait pas vers quelle marche ils sont
mais j'ai l'impression qu'ils seront
quand même dans un programme dit libéral
dont je vous demande d'aller regarder
l'ensemble des détails
ce projet est donc clair mais nous
savons quelle europe nous voulons et
nous savons qu'ils sont les hommes et
les femmes qui vont l'incarner et
aujourd'hui vous allez aussi voté pour
que il soit validé et que nous puissions
j'allais dire nous mettre en marche mais
nous le sommes déjà et comme le disait
un président de la république que
j'aimais beaucoup
on est à fond et à la fin on va
accélérer
françois-xavier je te remercie au nom de
tous au nom de tous parce que tu as
réussi à détruire en peu de temps
l'image caricaturale qu'on voulait faire
de toi et le calme avec lequel tu parles
la profondeur de tes propos les idées
que tu développes tes convictions vont
facilement l'emporter sur le plan de
communication stérile du président de la
république il y aura pas photo
vous le savez aussi notre liste elle
rassemble des sensibilités différentes
sont pas tous pareils et tant mieux
nous sommes pas tous pareils au sein des
républicains mais nous sommes
aujourd'hui avec des amis et je voudrais
que l'on applaudisse hervé morin qui l'a
qui a été président des centristes et
qu'il l'est toujours et qui continue à
penser que la droite et le centre
doivent s'allier lorsque les échéances
sont importantes parce que nous avons
une convergence d'idées une convergence
de conviction merci avait cette
cohérence et la clarté
elle n'existe pas chez nos adversaires
faudra quand même que un jour
moi j'essaye de faire un peu
l'intellectuel de temps en temps et de
comprendre ce qu'ils disent mais c'est
un peu compliqué de m'expliquer ce que
va à quoi va servir une agence des
démocraties créée par monsieur macro une
agence des démocraties c'est pas l'onu
c'est un machin probablement qui au
niveau européen
à mon avis va donner des leçons il va
dire toi tu y es bien toi j'ai pas bien
et à la fin tout le monde sera mal
il croit que la france de monsieur
macron qu'il sera bien et à la fin la
france de monsieur mc ren le sera seul
au tour des autres avec lequel on aura
rompu le dialogue pour moi comme
explique aussi ce que c'est madame le
pen dit la souveraineté monétaire doit
être récupérée sans sortir de l'euro ça
c'est champions quand même parce que
arrivé à trouver une monnaie qui est pas
l'euro qui nous donne la souveraineté
monétaire
que l'on partage avec les gens de la
zone euro c'est quand même une prouesse
technique faudra qu'il s'explique un
tout petit peu et on ne sort de
l'ambiguïté qu'à ses dépens et je pense
que ça va bien fonctionner alors comme
ils ont des contradictions comme ils ont
de la cohérence
ils ont choisi un système simple qu'on
connaît en politique qu'on connaît
d'ailleurs dans la dialectique de tous
les partis de l'extrême gauche à
l'extrême droite on simplifie c'est moi
ou le chaos c'est des progressistes où
les nationalistes c'est les gentils ou
les méchants et ben ça va pas marcher ça
va marcher parce que les français sont
un peuple démocratique apaisée mais
intelligent ils vont pas avoir envie de
refaire leur mec un peu manqué de la
présidentielle dans laquelle on
choisissait par défaut nous on a envie
maintenant de choisir par adhésion et ce
choix par adhésion
c'est nous je suis assez content
d'ailleurs de dire que nous sommes la
troisième voie ça avec moi je veux un
peu des études de médecine et claude
bernard qui a beaucoup inspiré quand
même la médecine moderne
il disait quand on vous dit de deux
choses l'une c'est une troisième est
bien quand monsieur maquereau ou 10 de
deux choses l'une
et bien c'est nous la troisième fois et
c'est nous qui allons reconquérir le
coeur des français
nous savons par ailleurs qu' il faut
changer l'europe changer l'europe pour
la sauver et je suis heureux de voir le
regard pertinent de joseph approuvé
cette stratégie
non les français sont européens mais ils
n'ont pas du tout envie d'avoir cette
agence et des normes supplémentaires qui
s'accumulent sur leur dos avec les taxes
qui vont aller avec
ils ont pas non plus envie de se faire
un freak site
il voit ce que les anglais ont de
difficultés à sortir sans sortir tout en
restant est alors que eux ils n'ont pas
l'amener monnaie unique et ils sont pas
dans l'espace schengen c'est dire que
nous nous voulons une europe qui à la
fois protège et se projette
nous voulons pas une europe replier sur
nous-mêmes nous voulons une europe qui
rassure elle va rassurer parce que
d'abord on éclaire sur le plan de
l'immigration de masse elle va rassurer
d'abord ensuite parce que on ne dit pas
qu'on va quitter l'europe où l'euro elle
rassure enfin parce que elle respecte
les peuples mais elle respecte aussi les
nations qui la composent et cet élément
là c'est l'élément rassurant est ce que
ça suffit non c'est une robe de projets
qu'on veut une europe qui se projette
dans l'avenir qui choisit de reparler au
monde de lui reparler à la fois dans le
langage de liberté qu'elle a toujours
porté mais reparler au monde aussi dans
le monde économique
comment l'europe pourrait-elle sans
broncher voir le numérique lui échapper
voir le développement durable lui
échapper nous avons besoin de cette
europe qui espère de cette europe qui se
projette dans l'avenir
oui nous avons besoin aussi d'une europe
qui assume sa civilisation sa culture et
son mode de vie
une civilisation c'est quoi c'est de
dire voilà ce que pour moi et l'homme
dans cette unité et nous savons que nous
pouvons passer ce message au monde une
culture c'est des scientifiques c'est
des héros c d art
sts qui ponctuent l'histoire d'un pays
et d'un peuple ou d'instinct ensemble en
disant voilà ce que nous sommes
et puis il ya un mode de vie le mode de
vie c'est celui qui que vous connaissez
qui fait que dans notre pays en europe
bien nous pouvons dire nous pouvons
critiquer nous pouvons nous moquer ne
pouvons croire au ciel ou ne pas y
croire
nous pouvons faire en sorte que
effectivement lorsque l'on exprès on
fait une expression cette expression ne
peut pas être condamnable
nous sommes un reflet effectivement de
ce mode de vie ce mode de vie vous le
connaissez c'est celui qui lorsque le
printemps arrive dans notre territoire
et à paris en particulier fait que des
hommes et des femmes sont sur le le même
café et que les jeunes filles continue à
rire avec la tête nue et bien c'est ça
notre mode de vie et ce mode de vie nous
n'y renoncerons pas nous n'y renoncerons
pas parce qu'il reflète notre pensée et
nous nous battrons jusqu'au bout pour
faire en sorte que ceux qui croient en
un dieu qui accepterait les gens les
mains souillées du sang des innocents
soient abattus nous les combattrons
comme disait camus
sans haine et sans pitié parce que c'est
la force de notre nation et que c'est la
force et le devoir de l'europe de
défendre sa culture sa dignité de
l'homme et notre civilisation
bien sûr les perdons joseph demeurer à
dresser une fois de plus à toi mais à
tous les députés européens et en
particulier affronte prosky notre leader
de la délégation aujourd'hui l'europe
c'est aussi la démocratie c'est la
liberté d'écrire c'est la liberté de la
presse et c'est aussi évidemment
l'indépendance de la justice
c'est ça le projet européen et il est
indissociable de la défense de notre
culture et de notre civilisation
chers amis l'europe à mes yeux
aujourd'hui est plus que jamais
nécessaire au monde et la france est
plus que jamais nécessaire à l'europe
l'europe c'est une espérance elle ne
dépend en grande partie d'une volonté
française pour l'heure france
transformant l'europe
soyons tous ensemble à ce rendez vous
électoral qui est en rendez vous pour
l'histoire vive la france vive l'europe
[Applaudissements]